got him for as long as I can remember my  life has been about one thing and over  the years the animal books turning pets  which turn into working with bears in  the wild this obsession is taking me up  into pine trees and down into bear dens  ok get back back but I do anything for  these animals and I know that I'm not  alone now I'm on a mission I'm  travelling across the country to find  young conservation driven by that same  passion  we'll get up close and personal with  wildlife to discover how they fit into  the bigger picture let me go rated I'll  find the people on the front lines of  the fight to understand our planet  protect the animals we share with it  gets a little messy along the way that's  just part of the job I'm Wes Larson  this is mission wild